[Musique]
g
cécile dachary bonjour bonjour claude
laurent bonjour merci d'être présente
sur le plateau de tv soixante dix huit
pour ce vip qui vous est entièrement
consacré vous êtes ici parce que vous
allez nous parler d'une association qui
s'appelle hélium qui regroupe un grand
nombre d'artistes principalement en
vallée de chevreuse et qui va bientôt
présenter un événement à
voisins-le-bretonneux une exposition
avec une cinquantaine de vos artistes se
prépare on peut déjà dire la date avant
de l'oublier 19 janvier au 3 février
voilà on reviendra sur les détails plus
tard alors cécile vous êtes à la fois la
présidente d'hélium et à la fois une
artiste que de laurent vous êtes une
artiste aussi et voilà on va remonter un
petit peu dans le temps
donc quand est née cette association par
exemple 1ère question elle vient men et
je pense en 2004 2005 voilà il y en a 15
ans une dizaine d'années nous allons
faire notre quinzième parcours donc ça
ça permet de chiffrer le temps qui passe
d'accord c'était à l'origine est là
c'était quoi le but de l'association
alors c'est le même qu'aujourd'hui c'est
valoriser les artistes de la vallée de
chevreuse en fait les faire connaître
les faire se rencontrer aussi et voilà
faire la promotion de la dette de la wii
les artistes presque en vallée de
chevreuse ouais parce que vous avez
l'impression que un constat peut-être
même que en vallée de chevreuse c'est
peut-être un peu compliqué de de se
retrouver que visuellement également
voilà on est on en est à la campagne
quasiment oui
et donc voilà on est chacun dans nos
ateliers
nos communes on est un peu loin les uns
des autres donc effectivement ça permet
de se rencontrer
l'union fait la force voilà tout à fait
et on lui vole à s'éloigner les uns des
autres puisque le parc est quand même
assez vaste donc effectivement ça permet
vous est financé par qui alors alors
financés au final un grand mort par les
artistes en fête
oui vous êtes une association oui une
adhésion pour voilà et puis on a
quelques subventions de deux ou trois
communes du parc et sont aussi surtout
beaucoup la principale du pnr alors le
pnr c'est là que naturel régional de la
vallée de chevreuse dec dans laquelle
vous vivez tous les deux vous voilà tout
à fait et on qu'il qui est le périmètre
sur lequel agit hélium d'une manière
générale principalement d'accord donc ça
c'est dit combien de d'artistes sont
alors je dirais 400e d'artistes voilà
qui sont pas forcément adhérents tous
les ans bien qu'il le devrait voilà on
est une centaine
genre je dois avoir un carnet d adresses
de 110 artistes en fête donc chaque
année il ya une centaine d'adhérents
d'abord et vous même vous y être depuis
longtemps
alors moi je sais pas je crois que ça
fait au moins six ans je suis peut-être
sept jeux c'est plus quelque chose comme
ça il vaut claude trois en trois ans
d'accord et vous êtes présidente alors
vous êtes présidente c'est un monde à
déterminer où ces huit cd mandat de
trois ans de trois ans la russe l'a fait
démarrer ma première année j'ai stern hu
est la première année à l'agefiph je
fais la suite d'un jean-paul privat qui
a été président pendant huit ans donc en
fait chaque artiste fait ce qui peut
enfin en plus de son travail d'artiste
je veux dire vous vous êtes présidente
chaque case on ferait partie les le
travail s'imagine comme dans toutes les
associations et un travail bénévole donc
je tiens donne le temps et les
compétences qu'il a à sa mesure selon
selon ses occupations professionnelles
qui lui permet ou permet pas voilà on a
tous aussi plein de choses à faire à
côté forcément mais apparemment ça
marche bien parce que quinze ans c'est
quand même un bel âge ah oui tout à fait
et puis ça un de grande dimension oui on
est un peu nu on est quand même bien
connu sur le holà sur le territoire on
fait maintenant appel à nous souvent
pour quand et dans quelles circonstances
ont fait appel à vous par exemple si une
commune où
un projet de l'atelier d'artiste par
exemple sont ils pas nous consulter une
demande d'accord des choses comme ça
très bien alors si on est là aujourd'hui
ce n'est pas par hasard saison justement
parce que vous préparez une prochaine
exposition une exposition collective à
laquelle vont participer 50 artistes
pour voilà pile poil cette expo elle
chacun expose une oeuvre plusieurs
oeuvres comment savent pas fait non ça
dépend des artistes en temps là il avait
un espace alloué en fait donc ici à huy
après sa déroute la diners heure là
c'est tellement de ce qu'ils voulaient
proposer avec varrault 1 à 4,5 oeuvre
par artiste et vous même alors que moi
j'ai trois petites oeuvres
ouais on voit la fiche lasky et voilà là
sont vos oeuvres
voilà on reviendra sur notre travail
après et vous claude vous aimait
beaucoup le travail de votre président
mais je l'aï très bien général et vous
vous exposez combien d'oeuvres un
j'expose deux oeuvres un dessin est un
mannequin pain d'accord on va y revenir
si d'accord donc cette expo elle a lieu
à elle s'appelle hélium prend l'air l'a
déjà et ça je pense que ça a une
signification will titre
oui on voit là parce que comme je le
disais tout à l'heure hélium agit
principalement au coeur de la vallée du
pnr ouais canada les rangs autour de
chevreuse à ces quelques hommes l'une
vient chevrette cheuvreux balle à rémy
oui cheuvreux saint-rémy bonnel
st-arnaud saint forgeot boulet les
troubles voulait les molières et après
alors il ya des communes qui sont aussi
sur l'essonne voilà donc c'est le parc
le mariage pas le partage facile
ouais
voilà et donc voilà problèmes cardiaques
on a déjà fait une première édition il
ya deux ou trois ans d'une exposition
collective
un jour prochain train qu'on a ok appelé
aussi hélium prend l'air parce que
c'était les dom sortais de son
territoire habituel en fait d'accord la
dr ailleurs en fait et c'est aussi pour
nous une manière de nous faire connaître
justement ce qu'on est hors de notre
périmètre habituel par des gens qui
pourraient ne pas connaître
l'association et les artistes qu'on
représente d'accord donc là c'est les
voisins le bretonneux et une commune
limitrophe du parc
oui pu céder toujours comme une parte
parte comme comme une porte départ oui
mais voilà pour faire passer la loi
voilà c'est légèrement excentré hors de
l'ordinaire
voilà voilà voilà et du coup ça vous
permet wii 2 comme vous disiez d'accéder
à un autre public des larges haïr l
affaire est que terre à fait d'accord
donc ça va durer trois week-end en
week-end voilà les mercredis et
vendredis après-midi 14 18 heures tout à
fait les samedis dimanches 14 19 heures
voilà
et ce sont les artistes qui se
débrouille pour assurer la permanence à
son tour de rôle on tourne ya beaucoup
d'artistes en même temps ça le qatar
tista chaque fois sur place minimum
minimum donc on a une chance de
rencontrer au moins quatre assists là on
y allons et pouvoir discuter avec eux de
leurs oeuvres
c'est elle qui est sympa où ils sont
tenus il faudra éviter si on intéressé
par un travail d'artiste pas hésiter à
en parler
oui elle mangeait un moyen de le
rencontrer un autre horaire d'accord
très bien alors maintenant j'aimerais
qu'on parle de votre travail personnel
cécile
comment est-ce qu'on peut le définir
alors moi je suis ce qu'on appelle une
plasticienne en fait parce que j'utilise
plein de matériaux divocer dans mon
travail en voilà l'enjeu au matériau
voilà ça la preuve d'ailleurs puisque à
des matériaux de récupération il ya du
tissu et du fils qui sont mes matériaux
de prédilection oui mais il ya aussi de
la céramique pas ce que je fais aussi de
la céramique d'accord voilà et donc
ça c'était des pièces qui sont issus
d'une série que j'ai fait l'an dernier
qui s'appelait le sauvage en moi le fera
jean moinon la sauvageonne dans le
sauvage en moi en nous en fait parce que
c'était une manière générale en d'accord
voilà donc c'est une série de portraits
et autoportraits sauvage de sauvages
sont des vraies cornes
alors il y en a à baiona à gauche et des
vraies cornes à droite cds comme que
j'ai fait en céramique d'accord et vous
crocheter et voilà je fais beaucoup de
choses au crochet en fait ce que je
disais tout à l'heure mon matériau
principal c'est le fils ouais et donc
tomblaine voilà et non que je crochète
que je brode je le dise pas mais
j'utilise aussi des tissus dans mon
travail c'est donc de la céramique mais
c'est et les chats ne s'est pas limité à
ça je peux faire des installations avec
d'autres matériaux d'accord et quand on
vous dit que votre travail évoque
éventuellement joana vasconcelos vous
prenez bien oui je le prends très bien
bon alors ça va je le prends très très
bien sa faveur et vous avez toujours
travaillé ces matériaux la wii en fait
oui en fait oui parce que je débats vous
avez une formation de alors j'ai une
formation d'arts appliqués les colonnes
olivier de serres well ntsama je suis
issu d'une famille où tout le monde
tricoter crocheter braudel et la zambie
et en fait sortis l'école je suis rentré
en bureau de style notamment chez
cacharel pendant des années dit il
la gt gt designer textile pendant
longtemps donc c'est bon pied mon
matériau d'accord très bien et
maintenant claude laurent artistes'
comment est ce que vous vous définissez
êtes vous parle près de vous je dirais
peintre sur tous supports
parce que le verrou soir je le peins
tout ce qui vous passe sous la main
ailleurs géré aussi je transforme jeu
badigeonne n'est qu'un petit jeune et
peigné alors justement ce qu'on voit à
l'écran
ce sont des mannequins des 25 livres et
mannequin cloud vitrée du vitrine oui ça
c'est assez récurrent dans votre oeuvre
ben c'est un support récurrents vous en
faites plusieurs là j'en ai sept dans
l'atelier commence à prendre de la place
le message alors il faut qu'elle prenne
esquerdes belle occasion de rien oui
voilà vous utilisez qu'elle quel
matériau enfin je peins avec la peinture
à clé qui est maintenant beaucoup de
bosses cas c'est facile à manier et
aussi la bombe d'accord ensuite donc les
mannequins qu'est-ce que vous avez
d'autres comme support bon au départ
beaucoup de tableaux mais des meubles
des objets tout m'a dit que vous aviez
aussi peint sur un mur d'azur et j'aime
beaucoup les grands murs de la commune
de la vallée de chevreuse et et où
c'était à boulay les trous ouais vous
avez pas un mur
oui enfin de katz était 1er df les
petites maisons à oui d'accord donc les
quatre oui vous aimez les grandes
surfaces aussi parce que le geste est
différée libéré libre que soyons plus
c'est petit plus on se contraint dans
l'espace comme c'est normal d'accord ok
et apparemment vous aimez les couleurs
fortes alors les maires primaire je
prends les quatre couleurs dit pour moi
symbolique du monde donc rouge noir
blanc jaune d'accord ensuite ce bleu
vert c'est le mélange de du ciel et de
la nature safed le vert d'accord mais je
peux plus peindre que de blank de si je
dois intégrer tout le monde dans mon
travail très bien voilà donc vous
excuser aussi comme on l'a dit tout à
l'heure
bientôt à voisins le bretonneux et si
jamais des artistes nous regarde je suis
sûr qu'il y en a d'ailleurs comment
adhérer à votre association il ya alors
en fait on a comme les portes sont
encore ouvertes le 8 août a fait tout à
fait il n'y a pas de souci mais par
contre on a quand même un petit comité
de sélection mais j'imagine
voilà ce qu'on peut pas falloir envoyer
à gérer cette sélection c'est pas
vraiment un jury mais on a menacé tous
les nombreuses heures qui seraient eux
ont fait des commissions régulièrement
et voilà n'accepte pas on accepte ou pas
oui quand on n'est pas acceptée on peut
toujours retenter le coup l'année
suivante ou là n'est encore pas tous les
ans ouais ouais ouais pourquoi pas et
vous êtes aussi à l'origine des parcours
d'ateliers d'artisanat qui ont lieu en
octobre celui là est dépassé puisque
l'usiné octobre 18 donc le prochain et
aussi des photographes
on voit des photos oui alors oui on a
tous à présent pour les artistes
tous les artistes ou les médiateurs des
sculpteurs des photographes
y'a même des impôts est ca de la musique
des cui aidé vivant il ya du spectacle
manière si souvent pendant le parcours
notamment de la danse du chant des
lectures et le fauche un parcours et
donc les deux les deux premières
week-end d'octobre
oui on en reparlera plus tard en octobre
19 bon mais écoutez un gros merci tout
cas deux d'être venu on a hâte de se
rendre de cette magnifique exposition
très riche avec tout un tas d'artistes à
aller admirer merci émouvant hélium si
on reverra pas
[Musique]